why does Donald Trump's approval rating
matter those many reasons it helps us
understand whether his agenda is
resonating with the American people it
tells us not just whether progressives
or moderates are abandoning Trump but it
also tells us whether Trump's own base
might be abandoning him it suggests
quite a bit about whether other
Republican elected officials will start
bailing on Donald Trump which would not
be good given the endless scandals that
are surrounding him there's this pretty
long list of reasons why Trump's
approval rating matters and in addition
to historical context I told you last
week that Trump has the lowest approval
rating in the history of approval
ratings at the six-month mark of all
presidencies during the polling era and
it was not just one poll that is
painting this disastrous picture for
Donald Trump and there's this popular
tactic of the right which is they'll
pick one poll that's not as bad for
Trump it's often Rasmussen and they'll
talk only about that one so it's common
to see right wing websites like Drudge
Report say 50% approval for Trump and
then you see oh it's it's just one
Rasmussen poll or something like that
that's becoming more and more difficult
to do last week Gallup had Trump at 37%
very close to the campaign to the
administration low of 35% popped up to
39% over the weekend but it's pretty bad
and disapproval is the key right Trump
is just short of 60 percent disapproval
according to Gallup we've got a new poll
from the American research group that
has Trump's approval at 35 percent even
Rasmussen which is often the one that
has Trump higher than all other polls
and they like to talk about how great
Trump is doing they have Trump at a
presidency low of 42 percent in their
poll and the question that we keep
coming up on is what would raise Trump's
approval rating what could raise Trump's
approval rating would it be a healthcare
victory I don't know I mean the
political victory of repealing Obamacare
and passing their silly bill will lead
to tens of millions of people losing
health care it's sort of hard to argue
that in the medium or long term that's
going to help Trump's approval rating
the tax plan
looking great for the passage of Donald
Trump's tax proposal that wall with
Mexico that Mexico would pay for I mean
that's just laughable who's even talking
about that right now and only 36% of
Americans even seem interested in that
which is why it's scary that Trump's
approval keeps dropping because the more
trumps approval drops and the further
away that some big legislative
accomplishment is that might boost his
approval rating it's more likely Pat
that Trump will become erratic with the
military and maybe do something in North
Korea I mean we know the lists of places
where Trump might do something that's
why it's scary you know I think those
Gallup polls are really telling because
it seems like with those he just stays
around 35 36 37 % that's his basement
that's where his base is and can't
really get much higher than that but you
see that his disapproval numbers are
going up right which makes me think that
people who are undecided on the
President or we're just gonna give him a
chance to see how it goes are not too
happy with them because they see there's
really not a long list of
accomplishments what can you point out
as the top accomplishment of his
administration killing the TPP maybe
yeah which happened three months before
he even took office so yeah I mean Trump
seems to have this base that's behind
him the polls seem to show that for now
the real shock to me from these polls is
that more than one out of three
Americans says I approve of the job
Trump is doing what do you approve of
this is someone who should be polling in
the low 20s by now given how ineffective
and scandal-ridden and incompetent he's
been and you can also wonder what would
it take for that base to abandon him and
I know we hear he could shoot people on
Fifth Avenue and nothing would happen
but I believe that there are events that
could take place which would start to
eat away at this apparent floor of
roughly 35%
I think tens of millions of people
losing health coverage could certainly
be one of those things it is not looking
good here at all and and the real
concern a lot of what Trump's doing is
reversible the real concern is that
between the Russia investigation getting
closer and closer to Trump and his
financial dealings and his businesses
etc that he will become erratic and do
something like bombing
that random runway in Syria except that
it will actually be much much worse the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad